Welcome to Science in the Hands of Scientists.
I'm Carl Zimmer and this afternoon we're going
to have a conversation about how science happens.
You know we have to bear in mind science is
not something that happens in the abstract.
People do science.
And so these are not you know gods who are
impervious to the forces that shape us.
They're human like the rest of us and they
deal with all sorts of factors that everybody
else does.
It can be everything from pressures to get
a job, to get funding.
It can be internal biases, there can be the
thirst for glory.
There are all sorts of things that can shape
how scientists decide to do science and what
they choose to do.
And that's what we're going to be talking
about this this afternoon.
We're going to have an open discussion about
the scientific process and how it works from
the classroom to the lab to the journal and
then out into the rest of the world.
So let me start now to introduce our panelists.
Our first guest this afternoon.
She is a principal investigator at the Tufts
Center For Regenerative and Developmental
Biology.
Please welcome Dany Spencer Adams.
Our next guest is the K.D.
Irani Professor of Philosophy at City College
of New York.
He works on the philosophy of science and
the nature of pseudoscience.
Please welcome Massimo Pigliucci.
Our third guest today is a distinguished writer
in residence at New York University's Arthur
Carter Journalism Institute.
He's the co-founder of Retraction Watch.
Full disclosure I have written about his work
for the New York Times.
So please welcome Ivan Oransky.
And last but certainly not least our final
guest is the editor in chief of Scientific
American.
She also oversees the journalists both the
Scientific American and at the Nature Journals..
Please welcome Mariette DiChristina.
So now that I have you all out.
Let's just start by just kinda talking about
how you make a scientist?
And maybe Dany I could start with you.
I mean so you have a lab and you are bringing
in students at Tufts who want to be scientists.
So how do you take them from being students
to people who are going to do science in the
21st century?
I would describe it mostly as like an internship
or or you.
Most of it is just being thrown right in.
Here, do this and there's a lot of supervising,
teaching specific things, specific skills,
specific techniques, protocols.
And then there's the other it's more of a
meta kind of approach where you have to teach
really that, you can call scientific thinking,
you could call it scientific method, but really
the idea that science is simply one way of
learning things.
And it's a it's been a very very powerful
very good way of learning things and it's
in some ways not not human-like.
I don't want to say inhuman.
I don't want to say super human but humans,
and I'm very much looking forward to the rest
of my panel to talk about this, but humans
have what's called confirmation bias and we
tend to recognize and remember the things
that confirm what we already believe.
And I just throw this out, most people if
you think about the newspapers you read.
You're not, most of us me included, I'm not
looking for new information.
I'm looking for confirmation for what I already
believe.
And you can say I knew it.
I knew it.
Yeah I knew that he shouldn't have been elected.
No names.
And I think that one really useful way to
think about science as a way of learning is
it's about overcoming confirmation bias.
So it's about phrasing a question in a way
that allows you to ignore what you believe
or even say OK, here's my idea.
Now I'm going to try and prove myself wrong.
And I can't think of any other way of learning
or thinking where that's what you do where
you say here's my terrific idea and now I'm
going to try and kill it.
And.
So.
Learning the intellectual skills of thinking
that way and asking questions that way and
controls are all about proving that what you
thought was going to happen wouldn't happen
that it was actually the injection you did
or it was actually because the air conditioner
was on or it was Thursday.
And I think that that that is what makes it
so powerful is that it's it's about overcoming
confirmation bias so that you can see what's
there rather than what you were expecting.
Do you find that you have to kind of push
them further with when they're sort of satisfied
that they have done enough to try to prove
themselves wrong, looks like I'm right.
Yeah absolutely it's it's.
There's there's you know it's crushing, it's
ego crushing.
You come in and you're so excited that you're
going to get to have wonderful conversations
and and there's fantastic questions and you're
going to find the answers and you're going
to change the world.
And.
First of all it's not like that.
It takes a very long time but you have to
constantly say alright how would you disprove
that?
How would you disprove that?
What's the proper control?
How do you know that, you know, how are you
going to interpret it if you get one of these
three possible results?
And what are you going to do if you get something
that you didn't predict at all?
It's there's it's you have to teach that and
the only way to teach that that we know of
at this point is simply to do it.
So students come in.
And.
You know when you get them started and then
you say OK no, that's wrong and that's wrong
and that's wrong and that's wrong.
And there's a there's a saying if you're not
failing most of the time you're not working
hard enough and that's a that's a hard thing
to get students through.
Absolutely yeah.
And Massimo, you have a long career not only
as a philosopher but but as a scientist and
have you know trained your own...
Yeah.
So I was in evolutionary biology.
I tend to agree with most of what you just
said.
I would even go even further in terms of I'm
a little more pessimistic about how the whole
thing works.
So ideally actually I think that lab works
a lot like a renaissance place where you go
and learn from Michelangelo from you know
Leonardo or whatever it is.
Yeah
It's a workshop you come in and you learn
because you are in constant contact and interaction
with not only the master, that would be the
PI, the principal investigator of the lab
but also the people that have been there for
a long time so senior students or post-docs
or things like that, right?
So you are immersed in an intellectual environment
and you're doing things every day and that's
how you learn how to do science.
But I honestly don't think actually that individually
we can as much as we it's a good idea to be
aware of it and try I don't think we can individually
overcome our confirmation bias.
The way it happens most of the time is precisely
because the rest of the people in the lab,
particularly the principal investigator tell
you no, that's not going to work.
Why don't you think about it that way.
And of course who does that for the PI, who
watch who watches the watchman?
That's the peer review outside of the lab
right so you have the PI himself or herself
has to get a grant proposal approved, those
have to go through the process of peer review.
Even if they are approved and the research
gets done, then you have to publish the results.
And yes it is ego crushing, I mean it's rejection
over and over and over.
And you just have to grow a thick skin and
deal with it.
But that's the way you learn it by doing it.
So, so.
When you when you look at the you know the
cohort of new scientists you know coming out
you know freshly minted Ph.D. in 2017, you
know what's it like for them starting out
now in science as opposed to 1997, 1987?
Is it the same?
Is it different?
In some respects it's the same it's the excitement
is still there.
And it's a great time for science for biology
for physics for for other disciplines but
at the same time you're also very conscious
these days that you know making a career in
academia, it's not it's not easy.
The number of people, typically when we advertise
for one position there's like 150 applicants
easily.
And I guarantee you a lot of them are actually
qualified for that position.
So it gets you know that you get into a period
of possibly several years where you go from
one post doc to the other or from one adjunct
position to the other.
And if you're lucky you're actually going
to make it by the time you're in the mid-thirties
or something into a beginning of a tenure,
tenure track.
So things are changing in that sense.
The job market in the sciences has gotten
worse over decades.
I mean the real peak period that was in the
1960s and early 70s where you could just go
out and get a job.
It hasn't been like that for a while and it's
increasingly less so.
But we also have a lot of talent.
We have a lot of people that I have you know
you do it because you have you're excited
about it.
You really have to want to experience the
joy of being a scientist in the lab.
You don't do it for the money because it doesn't
really pay that well and you don't do it for
the benefits because those come very late
in your career.
You have to sacrifice a number of things.
You do it because you love it.
So Ivan and Mariette, I mean you're you're
kind of more on the outside looking in on
this culture of science and I'm curious if
you see differences now in what it's like
for scientists to be starting out and launching
their careers in science now as opposed to
like when you started being journalists.
I don't know which one of you wants to jump
in?
I can start and then Mariette will probably
say something smarter and more scientific
than I will, how's that?
You know I was just struck, if I may for 10
seconds just say what Dany was saying about
I think about confirmation bias a lot.
Everything that you said about scientists
and how you really ideally want to wake up
every morning going how can I prove myself
wrong?
Well journalists are supposed to do that too.
And you know I am not going to claim that
I do that I wake up usually and you know check
Facebook.
But you know you you want to wake up and you
need an editor you need someone who's saying
well wait a second.
You know yeah you have that document but that
document doesn't really say what you think.
So I just want to reflect on that for a second.
IVAN I think that there are two I wouldn't
call them changes necessarily but they’ve
sort of accelerated.
And then I'd be interested to hear what others
think about this but there were sort of sort
of two phenomena that I think have accelerated.
One is what I would refer to as a sort of
metricization.
Right?
So everything is now measured.
And this is true in all walks of life, it’s
a sort of if you'll forgive me a little bit
of not philosophy exactly, political science
of a neo liberal idea that you know we can
measure everything.
And so that includes measuring impact of research
and that includes something called the impact
factor which is...
Describe how you measure the impact of somebody's
study.
How do you know?
So, often you know what a lot of it is based
on and I'm not here to defend this but just
to say that this is what happens is how often
are other scientists citing that work.
So if a tree falls in the forest and no one
hears it did it really fall?
If a paper is published and no one cites it
does it really matter?
And again I'm not condoning that but that
is what matters.
And so you turn that into a number, you turn
it into a number of numbers actually an ever-growing
sort of forest of numbers where you actually
have something called impact factor.
So the number of times on average I'm simplifying
here that a given, article in a given journal
are published and a lot of people and I kind
of am in this camp a bit say that this has
really had a dramatic effect on science and
not necessarily in a good way because everyone
is pushed to publish in these high impact
factor journals.
And so they publish a lot of really good science
but it also what it means is that tenure committees
promotions anyone who sort of helps you to
get ahead or is what you need to get through
to get a good peer review committees you know
Massimo was talking about peer reviews.
They all are looking for these numbers.
They're not necessarily reading the entire
paper anymore which is what you would hope
they would do.
But they're just looking at well is it in
this journal or that journal or what have
you.
The other thing very quickly that I think
is happening alongside this and really feeding
into it as well is that there was a blip and
now it's sort of looking more and more like
a blip, from 1998 to 2003 if you look at the
doubling.
So the NIH budget and that’s not the only
budget…
National Institute of Health, main funder
of biomedical research in the US.
Exactly.
The and this was a good thing for science
it meant that there were more there was more
funding obviously, there was twice as much
funding over that period of time.
But that stopped.
And so in fact you could argue and if you
look at inflation the amount of funding, federal
funding for the NIH has declined.
And yet all of those graduate students, postdoc
trainees, well they were all working somewhere
because labs just staffed up.
It was like some kind of boom it really was
a boom.
Well for this over the past whatever it is
14 years now we've gotten many many even more
than we had.
And it wasn't so good as as Massimo pointed
out since you know whether it's the 60s or
early 70s.
And so you had more and more people competing,
all needing to get all these numbers.
And lo and behold we were seeing a lot more
competition and that, a little bit of competition
is a really good thing.
Too much competition can really harm you.
Mariette?
Thanks very much and by the way it's fascinating
just to listen so far.
Absolutely wonderful.
So I have two things I would like to add just
reflecting on the ideas of confirmation bias,
on increasing competition, on impact factor.
On the two areas.
First of all I think a thing that we often
don't recognize is publishing's role in this
ecosystem, in both at the popular level so
the Scientific American level where I'm editor
in chief.
One way we can either foster haste in publication
or not is how do we jump on "this week salt
is bad for you.
This week it's good for you" you know.
Can we take the longer view provide context,
not be slaves to the embargo system, the system
where you know we all agree that a paper is
going to come out a period of time from now
and the journalists like me and like Ivan
we get a few days head notice to...and the
idea is that we will we will we will all publish
our stories at the same time and we'll have
had some some equal access to the experts
to do that without haste, but also comes with
a whole host of other challenges which we
may, we may or may not come onto later.
So that's that's one aspect.
So mass publications like Scientific American
and then the journals themselves.
How do we you know I am not a journal editor
although I work at a large publishing company
Springer Nature which which publishes 2000
around journals.
Including some of the biggest ones like Nature.
Including some of the ones with very high
impact factor very selective journals like
Nature and the Nature branded titles.
And how do we set standards there that in
fact slow down that haste to publish that
enable a little more checking and accuracy
like reproducibility check lists, like checking
methods and protocols, like supporting the
research community so those pressures that
people like Massimo are calling upon or noticing,
are are somewhat supported and slow down a
little bit.
And then I want to set the lens a tiny bit
more broadly outside of publishing.
So how do we as a society look at science
and treat it?
Do we jump for the latest headline or do we
start with our kids when they're very very
small.
Because researchers like Alison Gopnik will
point out we're all born researchers and you
don't have to believe me just watch any kid
in a high chair dropping different things
off to see how they fall and they bounce or
whatever.
So we're all born experimenting.
But over time in schools we're taught through
a series of classes that science is a set
of received wisdom.
And not something that you try and fail because
you know watching my own girls, one now in
college, one in high school, every every experiment
they take in every science class has the right
answer.
So this is kind of how the mass society is
left.
So I encourage us to look at those two lenses
you know one is the rule of publishing and
the ecosystem in the broader role of society
at large.
I have to say as a journalist when I was starting
out there there came a point, and it took
a little while for me to actually appreciate
how much of the work of a scientist was filling
out paperwork to get the money to do science.
And like I just sort of thought like well
somehow like the money just sort of like shows
up in a box or something and then the scientist
does the science, you know.
I mean when you read a you know you read a
biography of Einstein you don't read him filling
out an application to the National Science
Foundation.
You know you want to know how he came up with
E = MC squared.
But I just remember like I think that was
the one the one time it really hit me I went
to have, to interview a scientist, a biologist,
like a leading evolutionary biologist.
And I come into his office and he is like
hold on, I can't talk with you just yet.
And he was on a conference call with these
co-authors who all wanted to get this grant
and they were trying to figure out why it
was that their, their, their the essay they
wrote to get this money didn't fit on one
page.
Like there was something wrong with a font
and they couldn't figure out what was wrong
with the font.
Because they had like two or three words are
spilling off the end of this pdf and they're
like ahhhh...
If we don't get this all on one page there's
no chance we're going to get this money.
There's no chance we're going to be making
this great insight...I'm just looking at them
like I, I didn't come here for this.
And I had to wait like 20 minutes for them
to like fix their friggin font and apply for
the grant and then we could get to the science
and I'm just here wondering like.
I mean that's the sort of stuff we tend not
to report on.
But unless obviously like really....
I mean that must be a big part of what goes
on in terms of like your time and then also
how does that affect what you're going to
decide to study?
Yeah it's a very frustrating part of it and
it's something that I do wish more people
knew about because your tax dollars put me
through school.
You trained me and I'm trained to be in the
lab and how to ask a question, how to design
an experiment and I probably spend, I probably
spent 50 percent of my time writing the same
thing over and over again, changing the font,
changing the format, making sure this thing
is filled out and that's filled in.
And you know we have a rule never ever update
your software within one week of the due date
because it will get messed up.
Don't send from a Mac to a PC because it'll
come back wrong and it's it's very frustrating
to do that.
And the bigger the labs so that the more productive
the lab should be and can be and is, the more
time the PI's probably spent, sorry PI stands
for principal investigator and that's the
big scientist in the lab.
The person who gets all the credit even though
the work is done by many people.
60 to 70 percent of the time is spent doing
the paperwork, writing the story.
And on top of that, so the community and I
think the journalistic community as well is
is aware of these issues and is is trying
things.
Are there ways that we can get around this
and for example the journal development which
is the big journal in my field has recently
announced that you can submit it in any form
you want.
And they will deal with it.
They have decided that reviewers are capable
of reading a paper even if it's a different
font than the one they...so that's great.
That's a really nice thing.
Other journals are working there there are
some journals now that are connected up so
that if you don't get into the highest impact
one you can have it exactly you can have it
submitted to the next one down without doing
anything else.
Saving you time that you can spend on science.
Exactly.
So.
So trying to mitigate some of this silliness
that we spend our time on.
But even when you spend all this time I mean
if you look at the percentage of applications
that are accepted and lead to a grant.
Right.
Yeah.
I mean that's the other problem is is limited,
there are limited funds.
And the competition the competition is intense.
How does that affect the science that you
decide to do?
So the big granting agencies the National
Institutes of Health for which there is 18
I think and then and.
By the way the more important problem I think
is National Science Foundation so NIH is biomedical.
NSF it's everything else.
Everything else and its budget is very small
compared to NIH's.
But.
You.
So right now I think in my field it is the
places where I apply for money, you have to
be in the top four or five percent of your
peers for people who will understand what
you're trying to do.
Rank it and then they decide and you have
to be in the top four percent.
And if you're not you will lose, you know,
that's it.
There goes your salary.
And that's hard.
You're competing with people across the entire
nation and to stay in the top four percent.
It's one thing to be an A student in high
school.
It's quite another to be the only A, the one
you know one A in thousands.
And that's, so what you tend to do is you
you, these agencies what they do is they put
out these things called RFA, requests for
applications, and these are where they're
saying alright, Congress has decided that
what we should spend our money on this year
is mapping the brain.
And so they'll say they'll set aside OK we're
going to set aside $50 million for people
who want to map the brain and then they put
out these RFAs and you go to the website and
you think well OK I'm a brain person.
I'm going to go and I'm going to find out.
Is there money out there for doing this thing?
Well it turns out there isn’t, it turns
out that some congress person got put in there
that what really matters is this part of the
brain.
You know if you're studying the cerebellum
you've got a much better chance but if you're
studying the cortex we're just not interested
this year.
So yeah you might very well switch.
And so it ends up ultimately being guided
by Congress.
It's up to Congress to say, this is what's
on the agenda now.
This is what we think is important, and the
scientists are becoming more savvy about this.
And there's a lot more scientists now going
to Washington and we now get trained in how
to lobby for science because that it loops
back around to what you're going to be able,
what what passion, are you going to be able
to follow your passion in a direction that
you as the trained person think is the best
direction to go or are you going to have to
fit it into something that came down from
Congress.
How do you I mean how do you think about how
this fierce competition then affects the papers
that get published and then get reported on?
Do you see that do you see an influence happening
there?
Couple of things that I'd like to add to what
you guys have been talking about for the last
few minutes.
So NSF in my field we're talking about the
funding rate is five to six percent.
That means that when I was an active PI I
had to write a grant proposal every semester.
And two out of three will probably be rejected
which still it was much higher than...
That's a fabulous record.
That’s really good.
But that was frustrating.
That was a lot of time then yes you're right
you learn also how to lobby.
That's another chunk of time that goes away
from the science, do something that you are
not really set up to do to begin with.
But we have to realize that there's are a
couple of things going on.
First of all this is actually fairly new and
also it's not unavoidable because there are
other ways of doing things.
So it's new in the sense that NSF and all
the major federal agencies were created after
World War Two.
And that's why Einstein didn't have to do
that sort of stuff or Bohr didn't have to
do that sort of stuff because they were simply
not around.
Even even after they were created initially
there was a flood of money after the war was
you know in terms of economic expansion.
There was always you know science, especially
physics had a lot of cache.
And so they were just getting money.
The as you said when you introduce me I'm
the K.D.
Irani Professor Philosophy at City College,
well K.D.
Irani was hired you know like four decades
ago at City College because Einstein met him
at Princeton and he wrote to City College
and said, I like this guy.
You should hire him.
And he was hired.
That I guarantee you that's not going to happen
today.
It's not going to happen.
Turned out to be a good decision but nonetheless.
So all of these are actually fairly new and
it's gotten much much worse over the last
20, 30 years or so.
But there's also some very bizarre ways that
actually typical of the American system that
you don't necessarily find in other countries
in the world, even in other Western countries.
So NSF for instance for a long time has concentrated
more and more money on a smaller smaller number
of laboratories.
They go for the big project.
They go for the big things.
One of the reasons is as you were saying a
minute ago because that sells to Congress.
And I can tell you a story that occurred a
few years ago that I thought was hilarious.
And at the same time extremely sad.
So I was invited to a NSF retreat with a bunch
of other ecologists and biologists.
They told us, look we want to give you big
money.
But the way to give you big money is to attach
it to some kind of big project because otherwise
Congress is not going to do it.
And so they said you know try to tell us.
Think about it for this entire weekend.
Think about the equivalent in ecology of let's
say on an astronomical observatory or a satellite
or something like that or a particle accelerator.
So let's say that we want to give you not
the usual 500,000, 600,000 dollars but you
know 30 million dollars.
What would you do with that?
And it was hilarious because the answer was
I could hire 200 post docs because most of
them work in colleges' field work.
I don't need an observatory or a satellite.
I do need however a lot of people in the field
doing the actual work but that isn't the kind
of thing that is selling the project to Congress.
Other countries do it differently although
unfortunately more and more they're following
the American model because America is capable
of exporting a lot of good things and then
all those bad things and the rest of world
somehow buys it.
So Canada and most Europe for instance, they
do a different system where they give smaller
grants to a much larger number of labs.
And the way it works is you write much smaller
proposals instead of a 15-page proposal for
NSF, you have you know three or four pages
proposal and all you have to do is really
to maintain a certain publication record.
If you can show that over the last three years
you have published a decent number of papers
in decent journals and then you now have a
new idea you want to proceed in that direction.
They're going to look at it and go, yeah sure.
Good enough.
That's we're going to give you the money and
we'll see how it goes.
You know three years down the road.
That's not the case for NSF and things like
that.
So there are different ways of structuring
the system and I think part of the problem
is that of course the American system is the
one that does pump more money than anybody
else in scientific research and so we think
of science in the way in which it's done in
the United States.
But it's not the only model.
So what's your perspective on it?
I mean if it maybe pumps more money than many
others but the sad fact about U.S. research
is that the funding overall has been roughly
static since the 1980s and down.
And I actually get quite concerned.
I like science that provides solutions as
much as the next person because we know one
of the challenges and why Nobel Prizes take
so long is basic research may take decades
to then get to applied.
And surely nobody, surely Einstein who was
mentioned earlier today and this is a this
is something that maybe a lot of folks in
the audience have heard already, certainly
when he was working on relativity theories
there was never thinking about it being applied
in my iPhone with my GPS which of course we
do every day without thinking.
But even the iPhones have a couple of dozen
innovations in them themselves that nobody
thought of would be applied later on.
This is one challenge I see.
Some interesting models I also like are places
where in Europe, I think there's some great
leadership on this, funding the researcher
rather than the research project which I think
is encouraging.
So how would that work?
So a researcher has demonstrated through some
initial work over time that they have some
interesting lines of inquiry that they will
be pursuing and they get a block of money
for maybe five years at a time instead of
one study the next study, the next study.
I think that's quite interesting.
I think that's one way to go about it.
Another is for the publication piece of it
you might decide that the publication will
be OK as long as the methods and statistical
accuracy that you're going to use for analyses
are are agreed beforehand.
And one of our relatively newer journals Nature
Human Behavior is looking at this sort of
model as well so that the researchers know
when they've submitted something we can kind
of pre peer review almost that tells them
that when they get when they get done through
it they will get to publish something.
So models like that and also I'm thinking
broad, MIT and Harvard and how they have staff
scientists to help work and remove some of
that admin burden that many of the researchers
are shouldering.
You mentioned about grants, and you listening
to people as they're futzing through the grants.
I think the long story short of it is that
there are so many elements that challenge
research and we're going to have to take kind
of a multi-pronged approach to solving all
of these various problems.
I want to switch gears a little bit.
Ivan, maybe you could tell us a little bit
about Retraction Watch.
I want to sort of talk about some of the things
that with the panel as a whole that some of
the things that you kind of you know expose
as you as you run this site.
So.
So why, you know as a journalist why would
you say hey you know what I'm going to do
I'm going to set up a web site dedicated only
to retractions of scientific studies.
Like why why would you do that?
That's a great question Carl.
If I had the answer I probably wouldn't have
started it.
So Adam Marcus is my co-founder.
He and I launched Retraction Watch not quite
seven years ago now, it’ll be seven years
in August.
And to be honest the very basic idea there
were really two guiding principles or sort
of reasons why we were interested in doing
this.
In particular Adam had been reporting on retractions
for a while.
I'd been doing the same but credit where credit
is due, he had broken a couple of big stories.
One particular and it's a anesthesiology researcher
who ended up going to prison because of scientific
fraud.
It's a very rare phenomena, very rare event.
But that of course grabbed everyone's attention.
In fact I was at Scientific American at the
time and we reported on this after Adam did
and all that.
And so one, that sort of speaks to the fact
that often, scientific retractions, maybe
I'll just back up and explain what they are.
Sure.
Because I think that many people including
me until about seven years ago it wasn't quite
clear.
This is sort of if you will the and I'm going
to mix metaphors, I definitely shouldn't do
it with Massimo here but this is the nuclear
option if you will of self-correction or any
kind of correction in science.
So you're saying not only is there, was there
a problem with this this paper, this finding
maybe there's an error here but you shouldn't
trust it.
You shouldn't rely on it all.
You shouldn't cite it or if you do cite it
you should make it very clear that it's been
retracted.
It is again, retracted from the literature,
withdrawn from the literature.
Guidelines say it should still sit there in
the literature review marked really almost
with a scarlet letter, in fact often a red
stamp that says retracted on it.
And so that's what retraction is and what
Adam started seeing with these retractions
from this particular anesthesiologist was
wow there's a great big story here.
And as a journalist I mean there are investigative
journalists who I admire and just want to
be one one day but really Adam and I think
of ourselves as finding stories that are hiding
in plain sight and retractions are a great
example of that.
So here's a bunch of retractions.
They seem very arcane.
Why is this paper being retracted?
Oh wait a second this guy's made up all the
data for 25 different studies.
So there's that line at the end of a lot of
Hollywood movies you know, no no animals were
harmed in the making of this film and so it
was sort of like that no patients were harmed
in the making of this study because there
weren't actually any patients in this study.
So that's sort of a different take.
So there was that element.
But the other thing we noticed was that the
retraction notices themselves.
This is not a very transparent process.
I mean the process is not transparent.
The outcome is not transparent.
So the retraction notices themselves were
either, you know, some of them actually told
you what happened but a lot of them either
they were sort of mealy mouthed.
They wouldn't really tell you the whole story
or they would actually be wrong.
They would make something sound like it was
an honest error when in fact it was fraudulent.
And it turns out we've now learned you know
few years after we started the blog that A)
the number of retractions has dramatically
increased, it's far outpaced the amount of
papers being published, there’s a rate of
growth in that, think when you and I one of
the times we talked for the Times about a
study that came out showing that, the number
of retractions went up tenfold from about
40 per year in 2000 to 400 per year in 2010
and it's continued to grow.
That's out of about one and a half to two
million papers so it's still a very rare event.
And you know the other thing that's happened
is that we know that now two thirds of them
are due to misconduct or due to fraud.
So there's the sort of US federal definition
of fraud and it is or misconduct misconduct
which is something that has also been sort
of exported to other countries in a lot of,
a lot of agreement on that but it's FFP is
the, FFP is the, what do you call it, the
acronym.
So it's falsification, fabrication and plagiarism.
Plagiarism hopefully is self-evident to everyone
in the room.
But we can talk later if it isn't.
But falsification is you did an experiment
but it didn't go exactly the way you think
it should have gone to prove the sort of whatever
it is that you're trying to prove.
So you fudged the results a little bit.
Maybe you literally used Photoshop and you
take out that little band that shouldn't have
been there, a little spot.
Oh I'm sure that was just an error, you know
the the lab tech didn't have enough coffee
that morning and so I'll just erase that one.
That was an outlier.
The ultimate in confirmation bias.
That's complete confirmation bias.
I know I'm right.
I'll just treat the photograph just so everyone
knows it.
Right, and then the other half is fabrication
where you actually make it up like this guy
Scott Reuben did.
And so that's the sort of triad.
We've seen a lot of other things happening.
Crazy stories about people doing their own
peer review.
Actually manage to do the peer review of their
own papers.
I'm sure you're all familiar with peer reviews.
The idea is that it's been done by a peer.
Now I happen to think that I'm peerless so
there are no peers, but you actually are supposed
to have someone else do that.
It turns out…
It’s not a reflexive property.
So there have been just about 500 papers retracted
because people figured out a way to either
peer review the paper themselves or have someone
sort of do it for them so that they could
then peer review their paper and not in the
sort of usual way that we all know that happens.
But in a directed way.
So.
Mariette, what's your feeling on sort of you
know the issue with retracted papers and you
know perhaps reflecting these these pressures
were talking about?
Certainly acknowledging all the pressures
and actually I just want to put in you know
praise for for Retraction Watch and for scientists
who, you know let's not forget science is
a process.
I talked a little earlier about how we sometimes
in school in early school years treat it as
you know a series of received wisdom.
Bits of facts that everybody knows and that
that's always true.
But actually one of the things that's very
wonderful about science is that it tries to
embrace its corrections and self corrections
and so on.
And I also thought listening to to your excellent
outline Ivan that a thing we should mention
for folks who may be not familiar is that
you know the fact that you can reproduce something
doesn't make it right.
The fact that you can't reproduce it doesn't
make it wrong.
There are lots of things that happen in between.
Problems with your reagents, problems with
the techniques, with the methods used in the
lab.
And this is why I talked a little earlier
about what publishing outlets like mine can
help do, for one thing in our in our journals
they remove the restrictions they used to
have on length of methods.
We were talking about fitting a couple of
words on a page we used to have restrictions
and now online they can be much longer and
provide more detail so other researchers can
can help provide that course correction or
correction by checking something.
Or providing protocols or providing the raw
data which we now increasingly hook to the
figures that are in the papers as well.
All of these help the scientific communities
police themselves in addition to you know.
You're quite right there's of course there
is wrongdoing and science is ultimately done
by humans.
And they are flawed every so often but there
are these larger factors at play as well.
Right.
And even if even if people are not committing
fraud or misconduct or fabrication.
I mean there's also the issue of do you have
have you have your students challenge themselves
enough?
Or you know as I said like whoa I've got the
value I want, got to go publish, you know
rather than take…
P-hacking…
Known as p-hacking, right exactly.
And so I mean do you see that as a pressure
like you know like.
I mean maybe young scientists don't have the
luxury of spending another year or two saying
that I don't think that's quite right.
Let me make sure that my results are good.
Couple of comments to some things I've heard
here.
One is that another one of the perhaps unique
things about science is you don't have to
be right.
How do you mean?
So, science meanders.
I love the title of this salon.
An adjunct to that point is that the way scientific
paper scientific studies are reported, the
structure of a scientific paper: an introduction,
a section that describes how you did it, a
section that describes what you got and then
there's a whole section called the discussion
where you put in what you think it means and
you may be wrong and that's fine.
That's not the criterion.
The criterion is, did you do the right thing?
Did you answer that?
Did you do the right controls?
Did you use your techniques properly?
And the results, this was described to me
when I was a student, as the results is the
part of the paper that will never change.
When you did exactly what you have said in
the method and material section, is supposed
to be where you provide enough detail that
someone can replicate it.
And then there's the results.
That's what happened in that situation on
those days with those reagents and dadadada.
And it's one of the things I think that makes
these papers very boring because, you know
what's the fun part?
The fun part is what does it mean?
What does it tell me?
How do I interpret this?
But it's absolutely critical.
And I'm not the the person who's going to
figure out how to do this...
But that's the stuff that gets lost when you
switch to journalism.
Where you need to have a headline.
Where you need to sell a paper and you have
exactly two inches for your headline.
And it's... but the point I wanted to make
is that this is the structure of the paper
that convention that tradition is another
one of the ways that scientists police.
Is it going to come out right?
You say here's what I did and it's open game.
Anybody who wants to and who has the money
and equipment can replicate it and disagree
with you and you have this whole section that's
your your opinion and it's separated out and
it's this is the editorial part.
Here's what happened.
Here's the editorial part.
And and we build on each other.
We don't have one person who's studied, you
know, we have Newton and we have these wonderful
laws and that's great.
And he was wrong.
And it's, he was he was wrong when you try
to then apply them in other circumstances.
So but but science meanders and science builds.
And and of course you end up you know you
want your grant.
You want your headline.
You want those things but there are so many
little places built in to try to keep us honest.
To some extent these are now a question of
incentives and incentives can be structured
again differently.
So for instance we talk a lot about replication
but of course there's no incentive whatsoever
to replicate somebody else's results.
Why why why so explain why wouldn't scientists
want to spend their time trying to replicate
what someone else did?
Because it's only the adventure right.
You want to be the first one to get there.
Not the second one or the third one or the
fourth one.
And you can't publish it.
Usually you don't publish it.
Well why can't you publish it?
I mean…
Because most journals especially the high
impact journals want the novel stuff, the
sexy stuff, the things that nobody's done
before.
Right?
So even though that's slowly beginning to
change.
I mean there are some journals who accept
replications but those are not the ones that
you build your career you on.
You don't become famous as a scientist by
saying yeah yeah I checked these other the
guys work.
That was correct.
Nobody.
It just doesn't pay to arrive as number two
or three or four.
So that's one thing in terms of incentive
structure.
There's also the issue that the publish or
perish sort of culture arguably is always
been there at least since World War Two but
it has gotten worse precisely because there
is a large number of scientists, a large number
of journals.
How many journal do you guys publish?
At Science Nature it's about 2,000.
So you alone, Science Nature, publishes 2,000
journals.
That's one publishing house.
Right.
So the result of it is that you know you were
saying earlier if somebody publishes a paper
and nobody reads it or cites it the, you know,
what was that.
Well the thing that really opened my eyes
is a few years ago there was a study that
showed that of all the papers published in
major pop biology journals, the really top
notch journals, one third only is cited within
five years from publication.
That means two thirds, let's get let's get
this straight like two thirds of top papers,
published papers, published in top journals
never get cited period.
That's a lot of waste of money and energy.
The question though is, I'm sorry to interrupt
you but should citations, I mean citations
obviously there are many alternative metrics
as well.
Citation is important.
You know publishers also do have places increasingly
now for publishing negative results like a
scientific reports in my own journal group
will allow that kind of publication as help
for science at the time.
So incentives is a great point.
Yeah.
So you can change the structure of the of
the incentives.
So one of the things that would that some
people including my colleagues and I've been
doing when we got these 150 applications for
instance from young people, post docs, graduate
students that want a new job instead of doing
the bean counting and say OK so how many papers
you have, we say OK well that's nice.
You've published 20 papers in the last five
years now pick your top three.
The ones that you've got, not the ones that
have been published the best three journals
the top two the ones you think you made an
impact and I'll read them.
And the rest I'm just going to ignore because
it's just bean counting.
That I think brings back a little bit of quality
into quality control into it instead of just
doing the simple thing...
Rather than just churning out one paper after
another and just measuring by the pound.
And then I mean Adam and I have applauded
efforts like that because it actually gets
back to let's read the paper and let's understand
what he....
And who cares what... you could almost blind
yourself to what journal it’s in.
With all due respect to Nature.
I mean Nature Springer has every range, top
to bottom, in terms of...
I don't mean bottom.
But you know a range of selective or perhaps
less.
From highly selective to sound science.
But if I can be just sort of dark for a second
and I just because to put things in perspective,
you know we're talking you know you're talking
about you know an American university.
I think in Western Europe you see a lot of
the you know a lot of movements to do that
and Mariette was talking about some different
funding models that are I would argue progressive
in terms of that.
Certain parts of the world are going in exactly
the opposite direction.
So for example in China you get a half salary
bonus if you publish in a journal with a certain
impact factor.
It depends on your field and what have you.
You know...
So you get a paper in Nature you're going
to…
Nature?
Forget it.
I think they'd buy you a palace.
But I'm talking about you know a sort of a
respectable..
OK, respectable.
You get a paper in, just a respectable journal
and you're going to get six months of salary.
Is that what you're saying?
Right, and you can keep hitting the pinball
you know.
I don't know if that metaphor works anymore
today but you can keep hitting that you know
as many times.
I'm sure there's some limit what have you.
The point is I mean I like to think of myself
as a fairly you know I'm going to do what's
right and sort of all ethical person.
I've got to tell you if I you know was offered
the opportunity and had to figure out a way
to do it, I might sort of.
And even if I thought well I'm still doing
the right thing.
It's going to it's going to clearly do something.
And every country is somewhere on that spectrum
and you know even you know some for example
in the UK there's that and it's changed a
bit.
So this being maybe a little bit unfair but
there are these sort of framework exercises,
exercise frameworks where you look at, evaluation
frameworks, excuse me, where departments get
more money or your university gets more money
from the government if you have an average
impact factor in a certain number of papers
and this sort of thing.
So I applaud all of the efforts that people
are making to get away from that.
I think we just have to sort of look at this
globally and understand what's happening.
So I just want before we take some questions
I just wanted to switch it over a bit more
and more to focus more on sort of like that
next step from the from the journal to the
rest of the world like as stuff spreads out
through the news, through the magazines, the
newspapers, online and so.
Are are we sort of like on the outside of
this sort of dynamic?
Do we have nothing to do with it or are we
kind of.
Are we are we part of the problem?
We can get to the solution later.
Are we part of the problem?
We, who?
We, journalists…We will get confessions
from journalists first and then the scientists
can...
Just like the spectrum of anything.
Yeah, sure.
Many of us are click bait chasers.
Many of us are publishing the latest headline.
Many of us are....
So we're going to look for that paper with
the flashiest claim.
Yeah, it happens.
I'd be lying if I said it didn't.
How do we approach it, those of us who have
the privilege of you know in the case of Scientific
American, let me put that that on as editor-in-chief
there.
One of the first things I did when I became
editor-in-chief of Scientific American half
a dozen years ago was instead of having the
scientists write more in that received wisdom
kind of way which I was describing earlier
applied to education.
But we used to have a science or one of the
things I should have said earlier, in case
people don't know, is about half maybe more
of feature articles in Scientific American
are written by scientists.
They're written in collaboration with our
journalists so that they're accessible but
they're written by scientists.
About their work.
In the past we used to let the scientists
write in kind of a lecture style as if everything
was solved and they would look over the past
three or four years and it kind of came out
like here's all the received wisdom.
A thing that I tried to do and I think is
an example of I'd like to think, I hope to
think a productive way to approach it is tell
us your story as if it's what I did last summer.
What was your question?
How did you try to explore it?
When you made a mistake what happened there?
How did you get past it?
Who did you talk to you?
And so I actually invited the researchers,
and increasingly we do this at Scientific
American, to speak from a first person point
of view about them and their teams and embrace
the fact that science is meandering.
That we do make mistakes, that sometimes we
see things in the data that because of confirmation
bias or a mistake in the reagent or a counterfeit,
you know, technology that we bought that we
didn't know.
These things happen because it is a product
of human endeavor.
But because science is a process and an evidence
based one, eventually we right that over time.
Meaning we right in the sense of r-i-g-h-t,
rather than write it out.
So I think that's one way we can contribute.
Take the longer view.
Don't just be slavish to the thing that maybe
just happened that's the sharp headline but
try to provide the context.
And I think that's one place where at least
the journalism world that we participate in,
we can benefit this process.
I mean Carl you asked me about creating Retraction
Watch what made us want to do that.
I think one of the answers that I could also
give is that we wanted to write about that
process of science.
You know I have to say and so I was at Reuters
Health, I was running Reuters Health at the
time.
Reuters I'm sure you all know is a large wire
service.
And Reuters survives, like most wire services
do, on volume.
And our clients were very clear about how
much volume they wanted and how do you write,
and I can give you the numbers but it's somewhat
staggering and I don't want to scare people
but, how do you create that many stories per
week doing something other than writing about
every study that comes out that?
I'd like to think that we in some ways we're
for a professional audience, medical audience
that understood that, but and I like to think
we put the kind of context in that you would
see like in Health News Review which is a
great site that tells you, gives ideas about
how to cover medical studies in particular.
You know the sort of the the triad of coffee
chocolate and red wine.
Right?
I think that if no reporter ever wrote a story
about chocolate, coffee or red wine again
we'd all be better off.
I like two of those things.
The other one I don't actually drink.
That's OK.
But the point is I actually I wouldn't say
I had whiplash but I had a little cognitive
dissonance because here I was in my day job
running a website that you know not a website
but a wire service that had to pump out the
volume because we were reporting on single
studies, dozens of them every day.
And yet I was sort of thinking trying to think
a little bit more globally and slowing things
down and thinking about the experience of
science and what it all meant.
Maybe that was useful actually.
Maybe it sort of connected some dots for me.
But I think that's I think it would be great
if more journalists did the sort of work that
Mariette was describing which is in which
I think this salon is very much about which
is about how science really works.
We all need to get excited about what science
is doing for us but how do you really include
at least some of that.
Well I just want to touch on that before I
let the scientists pass judgment on the journalists.
The thing is that like I think when I became
a fan of Retraction Watch and then I started
reading about some of these people that were
featured there, which you know I started to
see more and more of these longer pieces about
some of the more notorious characters.
I you you you.
It was hard to look away because in the most
extreme cases where people would have to have
like twenty, thirty what's the record for
one person having to retract?
183 actually.
183 papers from one scientist that had to
be retracted and you start reading about these
people and they're just like they're sociopaths
and fascinating and you're like how did this
person go years and years and years lying
to everyone around them?
I mean that's... we love reading about that.
Is there a risk there that if you, that we're
going to swap this sort of naive idea of science,
scientist as hero who is only about the truth.
Are we gonna swap that for you know scientist
as sociopath trying to get the next grant?
I mean is that a risk?
Absolutely it is.
And it's something that you know I wouldn't
say we thought of on day one but that hit
us sort of smacked us in the face quite early.
In the way that we try and combat that if
you will both in our own minds and our own
work but also in terms of the public.
So one thing that has happened I don't know
that it would surprise anyone to learn that
a lot of what I would sort of frankly call
anti-science forces advocates have seized
upon what we do.
We're very popular with them.
Not all of them, but with some of them and
so we're very conscious of that.
One of the things that we've done to try and
combat that is to create something called,
this gets back to something that Mariette
was talking about in terms of trying to correct
the record, doing the right thing, We have
a "doing the right thing" award that we created
actually with Stat so it's me and Adam and
our column there at Stat.
We handed out the first one just about a month
ago.
And the idea there is to reward people who
do the right thing by correcting the record
at some costs to themselves because, you know
correcting the record is great.
Very important.
But you actually may face consequences if
you do that.
And I think we talked about what some of those
consequences can be and we call it, it's "doing
the right thing" so it's called the "Dirt"
award which is almost the acronym for it and
sometimes you have to get dirty to clean up
the center.
We like to market stuff too.
I think that if you if you approach it and
tell those stories as well, really try to
tell those stories as well I think you at
least over time can tell the whole picture.
You know.
So before we turn to some questions I just
want to hear from the scientists about what
you how you feel sort of the journalism world
fits into the issues that we've been raising
about you know the competition, the pressures
and so on.
You know I mean is the way that the journalism
is covering it kind of making things worse
or better.
I mean how what's your perspective on it?
The preferred answer of the scientist is I
never said that, the journalist made it up.
And sometimes that does happen or at least
there is some some major difference between
what comes out of my mouth and what comes
into print.
More often what happens is the scientist would
say I know I said that but I prefer that I
didn't.
You know.
We we're always getting these you know people
demanding to see our articles in advance.
I just want to check my quotes cause maybe
I said something I shouldn't have.
I think that one of the things that is changing
the equation.
Well two of the things that are changing the
equation is one, as you know, journalism is
now in its own interesting situation and I
have friends who are journalists and it's
not easy to find, maintain a job as a journalist
or often you're a freelancer.
That means even more pressure, even less time
to check stories even more pressure to go
for the sexy stuff and all that.
So that's one side of the equation.
The other side is more and more young scientists
especially beginning with PhD students and
post-docs and young investigators on tenure
track.
They start actually writing their own stuff.
They write blogs.
You know I write two blogs.
So I communicate directly to the public.
That that's interesting because then I have
journalists who come to me and want to talk
about something that I publish on my blog
not something to publish to the department
of literature.
And so that I think adds an interesting…I
mean I don't know where that it's going.
At the moment we're kind of welcoming it because
I do think that there is a good thing to add
the voices directly of the scientist.
Scientists should be more conscious about
talking to the general public.
After all as you were saying not only our
education but most of our money for research
and so forth does come directly or indirectly
from taxpayers.
And so it's just right that we spend some
of the time talking back to those people and
say, hey, you know here's what I'm doing and
why it is interesting.
So that's part of being a scientist.
That is part I think of being scientists.
And now it has been of course historically
this was a problem because your colleagues
will look at you and say you're wasting your
time.
Either you're wasting your time or you're
not a good enough scientist and that's why
you're doing that instead of another grant
proposal.
I think that's changing.
You know Planck famously said…Max Planck,
famously said that ideas in science get accepted
one funeral at a time you know because the
old people die.
I think that's true also for other attitudes
within science that is the old guard is retiring
and getting out of the way.
And so the new people have grown up with social
networks and Twitter and blogs and things
like that and I think that actually is almost
an unqualified good at the moment.
We'll see how that evolves for the next decade.
Dany I'll give you the last word before we
start taking questions…
I agree completely.
I think that so I don't begin to understand
the constraints that a journalist faces.
You know I have two inches to describe something
that took someone six years.
And when you have to go from the boring details
that make it science and make it trustworthy
and pick out whoo, this is the wow right?
We call it the gee whiz stuff.
You lose something and it can come out wrong
and I know that when I've worked with journalists
I asked to see it, to check the facts not
to check that I come off a certain way or.
But but facts can change when you change the
structure of the sentence.
If I if it takes me twenty words to say something
because I'm trying to be really accurate and
really precise and not let it get blown out
of proportion.
And you have to trim it down to six then it
becomes a sentence that you know you used
the word proof.
I used the word I'll say well I have evidence
that it's not this or that you know it takes
me...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, but you proved it…
Right and then that becomes proved.
And now - You have a headline to write and
now people think that scientists prove things.
And that I think is is is difficult.
I don't know what the answer is except a very
deep cultural shift and I hope things like
this festival will encourage it.
But there was a time where you needed to know
science to be considered an educated person
and now you need to know the humanities you
know.
You know I don't like Shakespeare you know.
But I think that you shouldn't be able to
avoid learning biology because you're an English
major.
I think that we have to go back to a time
where even if you do use the word prove, people
understand what that means in the context
of science.
They, they can read that and say oh OK what
that means, you know it's just it's automatic
that they will interpret that as we, we have
a lot of evidence that supports this idea
so we're running with it.
And if, and if that was part of our citizenship
almost I think that would that would help
a great deal.
I don't know how to make it happen.
OK.
So can we.
Well it's a little hard for me to see but
could we field some questions?
Oh there is an audience!
Hey look at that!
So we do have a microphone to pass out.
All right, so raise your hands high.
How about we start with that person.
OK.
How much of this problem in communicating
about science might be due to the fact that
you have some people, some philosophers who
would argue that scientific truth is as relative
a truth as it is simply as good as any other
form of truth.
I'm talking about the relativists and deconstructionists.
I'd be interested to hear what the panel would
say.
Well since I'm the resident philosopher on
the panel I'll take that one right.
Yeah.
So there is an issue with that but I really
believe I'm not I'm not usually an optimist
but I believe that that's done and over with
pretty much.
This was these so-called science wars mostly
that happened in the 1990s.
There was a small but vocal set of postmodernist
philosophers and sociologists, it wasn't just
philosophers who started going around saying,
well ‘science is socially constructed’
which of course is true.
We were saying earlier you know several times
science is a social enterprise.
It is socially constructed, in a sense in
a sense.
In another sense of course that social construction
is not independent of the outside world.
It's very highly constrained by the outside
world.
The response to that sort of extreme version
of postmodernism actually came both from scientists,
Alan Sokal here at NYU for instance, and especially
by philosophers of science.
Philosophers of science were very strong in
responding to that to that sort of extreme
criticism of science and I think actually
we are in a good place at the moment between
the two disciplines because there is a good
balance where the scientists themselves tend
to realize that, yes that there is in fact
quite a bit more of the human side to doing
science.
There is mistakes, there is fraud.
There is all sorts of stuff.
All right.
Do you have the microphone for someone else?
So my question is a topic which has been briefly
touched upon which is replicating research
and that there are no real incentives for
that.
Have any of you.
Do any of you have any ideas about how there
might be incentives to replicate studies?
Perhaps work into the system like a lot of
professors at universities are required to
teach.
Maybe graduate students are required to replicate
research before moving on to original stuff?
Yeah.
I'll address that.
I want to qualify that there's no incentive
to replicate.
Often.
So all results are comparisons.
You're always comparing what you've got to
something else.
And in many cases what you're comparing to
is what the last guy got.
So you're replicating it as one of your controls.
So it does happen.
What you suggest is a great idea.
And one way of teaching and getting your students
kind of up to whatever boundary you're pushing
is to have them replicate what's been done.
That's how you can learn a technique.
That's how you can really understand what
what the person, you're your competitor found.
Do you agree with it?
Don't you agree with it?
And you can use that as a teaching tool.
So there's ways of sneaking it in.
You can't just publish a paper where you replicate
what everybody else did.
But often you can include the replication
as that which you are building upon.
So here's where we started.
Yes we agree.
But now look at this.
And so I think that it's.
It's not as clear cut as we we have no incentive
to replicate.
I think it's you can use it.
Any other ideas about fixing the replication.
Well I think too, if I can consider two quick
opposite sides of the same coin maybe.
One is that I would argue and it gets back
to something Massimo was saying earlier that
I would actually argue that some people have
made their careers or are starting to in this
case, I think things are changing.
Not so much in replicating but actually failing
to replicate.
Now that creates its own sort of bias because
if you become known as the person who always
goes out and fails to replicate then you kind
of show up to the saloon with a you know a
couple of guns or something, six shooters.
But so that's but that there can be a sort
of incentive of its own to do that.
And the other is probably talking out of the
other side of my mouth when I was talking
earlier about we have too many metrics.
Well if we're going to be stuck with metrics
well we could make this into a metric you
could have something out of and I reckon you
know sort of at a very high level called for
a bunch years ago, a transparency index like
you know out of a given journal, out of a
given maybe lab, out of a given sort of field.
What are the, what is the likelihood that
that's that something actually holds up and
if you turn that into a positive if you say
well the higher it is the better then maybe
you'll have something that sticks.
But again those are not particularly well-formed
ideas to be honest
I mean what about I mean on the journalism
side I mean what could we do to sort of let
people know that that one little crazy sounding
paper in Science we'll say is you know it
may not be the last word.
You know it turned out that was wrong.
The article you wrote no or I mean how do
we sort of build in that process of replication
into the journalism about science?
I mean, maybe I'm gonna sound like a broken
record at this point because part of what
we do when we choose what we cover is we celebrate
things in effect because we we've chosen that
we've curated a story and presented it.
I think one way we do that is we portray the
lives of scientists.
We portray the what is it like a lab?
The Times used to have a piece that I loved
a lot which was about working life of scientists.
I've had many researchers tell me that you
know you have no idea how long I spent writing
this software program so I could do this piece
of research on cosmology.
It's all of that that we should celebrate
as well not just the result that pops out.
So yah, that's one way we can contribute.
We were talking a little about the discussion
section in experiments and how that's really
just not the science of it and yet it's the
most interesting part.
So I'm a philosophy student and a lot of what
we do when I'm in classes doing research is
we look at the discussion section in science
pieces and so I'm not really reading the rest
of the experiment or I am but like briefly.
I'm looking at what their conclusion was and
what they're discussing.
So really should we be taking a lot out of
that and like writing our own papers off of
it or should we be used to looking at the
experiment side?
Wow.
That's a great question.
The discussion section is part of the science.
It's the most educated mind at that point,
the person who did the work and got those
results.
At that moment that is the most educated guess
and it's often right.
You develop experience.
You develop, you know, you learn as you go.
So it's certainly part of the science and
the interpretation is very interesting and
putting it in context is very interesting.
But I would say that you might be able to
put a layer of depth into your understanding
of how we got to that if you look at the results,
if you look at the part that is just here
is what we've got.
And I, and then say you know the process that
we go through.
OK.
How many different ways could I have gotten
the same thing?
And then you go through and then you go in
the discussion and you say well I might have
gotten it if A was true but I could also gotten
it if B was true.
And that process of forcing yourself to not
fall in love with one interpretation.
The danger of falling in love with an idea.
And we do.
We fall in love with our ideas.
It's very creative.
And I think that if you were to go and look
at the difference between what's in the results
section, where they say this is what happened.
And how that gets turned into a discussion
section where there's the philosophical underpinnings
of it where you're thinking about necessity
and sufficiency.
And you're thinking about all those those
very basic intellectual processes that are
behind it.
I think that you might get something different
and very interesting comparing the you know
just the facts ma'am to here's how I interpret
this and here's what I think is important
about it.
I think that would be an interesting way to
look at it.
But there's an additional problem there, right.
So there is a method problem if you will,
which is scientific papers are in a sense
a piece of fiction.
Some of them actually are fiction.
Some of them really are fiction but all of
them to some extent are if fact a piece of
fiction in the sense that it really didn't
happen like that.
This is the structure of the paper is incredibly
artificial.
There's this introduction…
You’re saying like, I did this and then
I did this… and then I had this great idea…
…First of all…You don't even do that.
You write in third person.
They did that.
We did that.
Right, passive voice.
That's changing fortunately.
So it's it's like you're supposed to be distancing
yourself as much as possible.
Right.
So this is a very structured thing.
The introduction, what tools and methods,
the results and the conclusion and the discussion.
And they're supposed to have these really
different functions as if you're sort of pretending
that when you write the introduction that
you really don't know at that point how things
are gonna turn out.
But of course you've written the introduction
after you've done experiments after you've
done the data analysis.
In fact typically the way I used I don't know
how other people do it but the way I taught
my students to writing the papers was never
to start with the introduction.
You always start with the results.
Because you want to have the results in good
shape and then you know the diagrams and tables
and all that.
After you've done that then you sort of write,
you write the actual narrative that goes with
the results.
Then maybe you're going back to a little bit
of introduction, discussion and you go back
and forth until everything fits together.
So it's a work of fiction.
It's everything is put in a way that it's
not the way it actually went, but…I don't
mean fiction in the ways that you obviously
have that problematic but it does give the
impression, even to the scientists themselves,
that there is a lot more objectivity, a lot
more rigor a lot more sort of well it had
to be that way than there really is.
Science is much more fun than that, but it's
much more unpredictable.
Imagine if you were actually running a scientific
paper the way in which you write a novel or
or little you know short stories like oh we
started out this way.
We were having coffee that morning when my
graduate student he said you know ‘damn,
we don’t understand this.’
That would be much more true to the way things
actually happened.
I'm not suggesting that's practical.
But you know what you need to keep in mind
that when you read a scientific paper you
there is a lot of rearranging of stuff going
on.
When I interview somebody for an article I'm
always just, I just kind of like set the paper
aside and say hey come on how did this really
happen?
And you get a bizarre story that you never
would have guessed from reading the paper.
Much more interesting.
Yes.
I’d just like to thank everybody for attending
today.
So thank you all for coming.